bonjour à tous vous êtes bien sur lcp
public sénat nous sommes avec michael
bonjour et c'est l'heure de parlement
hebdo 45 minutes pour refaire
l'actualité politique et parlementaire
et on commence avec les titres de cette
émission c'était un moment fort à
l'assemblée les témoignages des familles
et proches des victimes des attentats du
13 novembre ont été entendus par une
commission d'enquêté parlementaire elles
ont dénoncé les dysfonctionnements et le
manque drastique d'information la
semaine politique mais l'otan du
ambiance tendue chez les républicains
les concurrents pour la primaire se sont
retrouvés au conseil national porte de
versailles affichent est évidemment leur
rivalité avec en toile de fond les
primaires réduire le chômage c'est
l'objectif de françois hollande est
aussi du projet de loi sur le travail
qui sera bientôt présenté mais la même
connerie par myriam el khomri le texte
prévoit d'assouplir le temps de travail
des débats tendus en perspective à
l'assemblée notre invité cette semaine
pour commenter toute cette actualité
bernard debré bonjour bonjour député
paris les républicains auteurs de ce
livre de un homme d'action de l'hôpital
à la politique on en reparlera un petit
peu plus tard on va bien sûr aussi
commencer par l'actualité très politique
c'était le week-end dernier
ça s'est passé porte de versailles 4 oui
les républicains ont tenu leur conseil
national
ce devait être une journée de débats sur
la ligne politique du parti ce fut tant
un concert un peu cacophonique deux
voies différentes et une tête d'affiche
nicolas sarkozy qui a présenté son
programme pour l'avenir sujet de quentin
calme et il n'a pas quitté la tribune
pendant les deux jours du conseil
national nicolas sarkozy s'est voulu à
l'écouté des militants et en clôture il
présente un programme qu'il veut comme
le projet du parti
le texte que je vais vous présenter
m'engage engage la direction de notre
mouvement est naturellement sur projet
collectif ambitieux si vous voulez
qu'ils aient du sens il engagera notre
mouvement et chacun de ses membres un
texte transmis à toutes les fédérations
puis au bureau politique qui pourront
l'amendé pour être soumis au vote des
adhérents en avril et qui se veut être
une base programmatique pour tous les
candidats à la primaire
chaque candidat de moment venu déclinera
le projet spécifique mais autour de ces
églises de force je ne vois pas de
difficultés pour qu'on travaille
ensemble il faut une ligne pour le parti
et en même temps chacun devra reposer
son propre projet pour les candidats
déjà lancé dans la course à la primaire
pas question de suivre ce texte à la
lettre dont j'entends mon poids vont
certainement pas ça y'a plus primaires
et c'est très important de réussir les
primaires c'est de nos plantes aux
imprimeurs nous prendrons présidentielle
chacun d'entre eux candidat moi même
comme candidat nous exprimerons notre
projet et les électeurs de la primaire
c'est à dire au delà des militants tous
les français pourront trancher
nadine morano jean françois copé bientôt
bruno le maire et nathalie kosciusko
morizet il pourrait être une dizaine à
se présenter à cette primaire le clan
sarkozy prépare donc déjà les écarts sur
la ligne c'est la base pour tout le
monde après chacun ajoute diffère c'est
par voie là mais il y aura ceux qui sont
dans la ligne ceux qui sont à côté de la
ligne
ceux qui sont très loin de la ligne et
puis les électeurs choisiront utiliser
le parti pour faire avancer sa vision
tout en invoquant la démocratie interne
pour se légitimer une tactique que
nicolas sarkozy entend exploiter jusqu'à
l'été et ainsi attendre le dernier
moment pour annoncer sa candidature
alors bernard debré je voudrais savoir
ou est ce que vous êtes par rapport à la
ligne vous êtes loin de la ligne très
loin de la ligne comme a dit roger
karoutchi ou alors très proche de la
ligne ou des essais très pathétique
à quand les pattes et pourquoi pas ce qu
on voit qu'il va y avoir une primaire et
cette primaire est nécessaire est saine
elle a eu lieu chez les socialistes
elle a été parfaitement bien acceptée il
y a eu quelques batailles d'hommes ce
qui est tout à fait normal ces primaires
ont lieu partout dans le monde nous
avons une primaire
et et nicolas sarkozy voudrait de façon
un peu pathétique du dévoila alors je
fais un programme mais tout le monde
doit adhérer au programme
là ce qui fait que la primaire sera un
concours de beauté nous ça veut dire que
la primaire aujourd hui elle ne sert pas
à rien dans cette dans ce contact dans
ces conditions là un texte la primaire
est indispensable mais pourquoi voulez
vous imposer à tous les candidats de la
primaire d'avoir le même programme
je dis je le répète on va vers un
concours de beauté
abba juppé il est pas mal oui mais
j'aime mieux la cravate de fillon
puisqu'ils ont le même programme que
vous craignez de dos et qu'on ne regarde
pas les programmes mais simplement les
personnalités on va regarder les
programmes c'est pour ça que ce qu'a
voulu faire nicolas sarkozy était un peu
pathétique
il a voulu prendre en charge lui-même
son propre programme et l'imposer nom
vous dit qu'ils étaient prêts hier
partout que c'est tout à fait normal que
ça lui donne dans les deux camps mais
est ce qu'il n'ya pas quand même un peu
trop de candidats presque 10 pour
pourquoi pas plus qu est ce que vous
dites sur sa tournée droit de s'exprimer
tout simplement parce que il y aura
beaucoup moins de candidats vous
n'oubliez pas qu'il y a la nécessité
d'avoir des parrainages dont beaucoup de
départements qu'il faut des députés des
sénateurs il faut beaucoup moins
beaucoup qu'il n'y arrivons pas
souvenez-vous le pen à un moment donné
on pensait qu'il n'irait pas des petits
candidats comme je ne citerai pas pour
ne pas leur faire de peine mais des
petits candidats vont faire un petit
tour sur vous sans alléger restera sur
la ligne de départ à votre avis au rien
sur à 6 ou 7 mai à 6 ou 7 c'est beaucoup
oui c'est comme pour les socialistes il
était six ou sept également et jette une
bonne chose
on va pas faire une primaire à 2 une
question si très importante qu'il ya un
petit peu agité pendant ce week-end
c'est la question des législatives et
des candidatures pour ces législatives
les investitures
nicolas sarkozy souhaite se prononcer
avant le mois de juin je veux que vous
souriez j'ai complètement pathétique
également il est en train de dire aux
députés des si vous êtes contre moi vous
serez pas investi parce que c'est moi
qui avais si avant le mois de juin
mais il est des prix et les députés lui
dise mais nous on ne veut pas il est
tout à fait naturel que celui qui sera
désigné au primaire et qui a toutes les
chances d'être élus décident avec le
mouvement qui sera investi on peut pas
investir avant c'est ce qui s'est passé
pour les socialistes avec un créneau
bris martine aubry a investi chaud
pourquoi une dizaine de d'écologistes
regardez maintenant comment il s'en
dépêtre c'est très difficile alors je ne
voudrais pas qu météo de ce que je sois
nommé socialiste ni l'erreur parce que
ce serait une très grave erreur ni et je
crois cette espèce de coup de force en
une hanche et moi qui nomme et je vais
je vais décider qui sera candidat qui
pourra être là bien sûr je déciderai de
ce que j'ai envie et qui me soutiendront
par deux et on va passer au reste de
l'actualité de ce lundi à l'assemblée
nationale et une trentaine de
parlementaires penche sur les moyens de
l'état face aux terroristes c'est une
commission denquête qui est née après
les attentats du 13 novembre regardez ce
reportage
d'alix pichot les parlementaires se sont
donné cinq mois pour comprendre la
première étape
donner la parole aux victimes qu'elles
soient des proches ou des rescapés
georges sa ligne était le père de lola
décédé au bataclan devant les députés il
a dénoncé l'atroce en préparation dans
le dispositif d'urgence avait un numéro
de téléphone qui était injoignable
pendant des heures et des heures et des
heures puis la nécessité d'appeler tout
un ensemble de plateformes téléphoniques
des hôpitaux
et puis au final une annonce du décès
qui est de la ddt de tout ce qu'on peut
imaginer comme ratage
l'accompagnement n'est pas à la hauteur
les victimes sont unanimes le
traumatisme psychologique doit aussi
être gérée mohamed s'est cassé trouvait
désarmée lorsqu'il a fallu trouver du
soutien pour sa fille blessée au
comptoir voltaire pas préparé à ça
arrivait à la maison il fallait trouver
il fallait trouver un suivi
psychologique elle avait elle avait peur
ne pouvait pas sortir au bout de dix
jours on a trouvé
on a trouvé une cellule qui sont venus à
la maison et par la suite mieux passé
gérer la souffrance invisible des
victimes mais aussi ouvrir une réflexion
plus large c'est ce que souhaitent les
associations réfléchissons un peu sur ce
qui a conduit notre société en arriver
là ce sont les enfants de la république
qui tue les enfants la république la
commission denquête n'en est qu'à ses
débuts mais les victimes ont beaucoup
d'attentes qu'elle ne s'en tiennent pas
aux moyens policiers de renseignements
et de déploiement de forces de l'ordre
mais aussi qu'elle s'interroge sur les
moyens de prévention des dérives
sectaires islamistes les députés
poursuivent leurs travaux ils devraient
entendre le premier ministre dès le mois
de mars
on le disait avec picasa nasa l'instant
il ya eu des témoignages très très fort
lors de ces commissions de cette
commission des paroles de deux victimes
à c'est assez dur à trans préparation à
dean victimes impossible de joie de
quiconque
nous avons été livrés à nous-mêmes etc
vous êtes médecin vous connaissez ce
genre de situation d'urgence est ce
qu'il ya eu des dysfonctionnements
mais oui on a eu et c'est obligatoire
pourquoi parce que même quand nous avons
eu des plans blancs et nous en avons eu
à l'assistance publique
jamais autant de morts et surtout autant
de blessés près de 400 blessés il ya eu
des attentats en janvier oui alors c'est
un problème le problème c'est qu'on n'a
pas tiré les leçons de janvier ni au
niveau état d'urgence
on aurait pu prendre l'état d'urgence
mais ça c'est une chose on va parler
juste après mais les leçons qu'on aurait
pu retenir elle n'aurait plus rien des
leçons curité des bons la sécurité des
lieux communs en particulier le bataclan
parce que vous ne pouvez pas à vous
opposer un thé à des terroristes quand
vous avez
vigile qui élaguent et désarmé d'absurde
et nous avons eu des ratages encore une
fois je suis pas là pour accuser je suis
là pour voir ce qui a mal tourné
pourquoi et comment on pourra faire si
jamais nous avons un nouvel attentat
fonctions ou à nouveau tram
si on reste sur votre domaine qui est
donc l'hôpital la médecine etc
est-ce que là vous avez reparlé juste
après ces attentats est ce que vous avez
décidé de faire d'autres choses
supplémentaires défie les samoa dessiner
mais là on a eu quelques problèmes parce
qu'on a eu trop de blessés on n'a pas eu
assez de matériel c'est à dire que comme
les 350 400 blessés qui arrivent il y
avait trois ou quatre hôpitaux qui était
désigné n'y a pas assez de matériel
matériel c'est quoi ces s'est dépeint ce
sont des des matelles chirurgicale ça a
été
limite limite limite et puis il ya eu
des difficultés au niveau de
l'hospitalisation parce que je n'ai pas
assez de lits où on a un afflux de 400
personnes comme ça c'est pas prévisible
mais c'est tellement exceptionnel
il faudra en tirer les conclusions mais
je voudrais quand même saluer tous les
médecins sur l'est qui sont allés et qui
sont allés spontanément spontanément
mais vous pouvez quand même du doigt des
manques que ce serait quoi dans les
hôpitaux mais en matière aussi de
prévention de la sécurité la prévention
renseignement vous savez j'ai vu un
ancien bâtonnier qui m'a dit une chose
terrifiant mais dit les frères kwasi ont
été écoutés le jour où on a décidé de ne
plus écouter les frères cochet on m'a
écouté mois pourquoi lui parce que
c'était les affaires sarkozy etc etc et
donc on a préféré écouter un bâtonnier
un avocat ce qui est absolument indécent
plutôt que de continuer à écouter les
frères kwasi mènera dans un masters sur
les questions de renseignement selon un
reportage dessus 4 oui on va rester
si vous voulez bien à l'assemblée après
les sénateurs les députés ont voté à
leur tour l'état d'urgence était mardi
l'état d'urgence a donc été prolongé les
députés ont voté ont validé la procédure
la séance a duré tard dans la nuit
état d'urgence contre état de droit les
positions se sont affrontés à
l'expulsion les députés ont massivement
voté pour la prorogation de l'état
d'urgence
seulement 31 votre contre les opposants
ont pourtant été cinq fois plus nombreux
que lors du premier vote en novembre
dernier face à un hémicycle clairsemé le
ministre de l'intérieur a défendu
chiffres à l'appui le bilan de l'état
d'urgence et son maintien l'état
d'urgence n'est pas synonyme
d'arbitraire est strictement encadrée
par la loi d'état d'urgence est donc un
élément de l'état de droit les bancs de
la droite et de l'udps et y sont acquis
à la cause pour eux l'état d'urgence se
justifie par une menace terroriste
toujours élevé de la menace c'est le
terrorisme islamiste
la menace ce n'est pas l'état d'urgence
à gauche certains y voient un mal
nécessaire mais des voix dissidentes se
font tout de même entendre
l'état d'exception que nous appellerons
état de sécurité est devenue la règle de
la république
une révolution sécuritaire est à
l'oeuvre en effet qui transforme
subrepticement notre société notre
société de liberté en société de
surveillance et de section mais pour le
rapporteur du texte la menace justifie
les moyens
je suis ma mère le terrorisme ça ne se
combat pas avec une fleur de tournesol
la france sera donc en état d'urgence
jusqu'au 26 mai prochain pour l'heure
quelques 285 assignation à résidence
sont toujours en vigueur avoir de vraies
pour rebondir à ce que disent les
rapporteurs pascal popelin la menace
justifie les moyens on ne combat pas le
terrorisme avec une fleur de tournesol
réponse à noël mamère qu'est ce que vous
dites vous c'est un peu à
l'emporte-pièce
le problème c'est qu'effectivement
l'état d'urgence qui avait été décrété
en novembre était légitime
j'ai voté pour la prolongation parce que
le ministre de l'intérieur nous a dit
qu'il y avait encore du travail à faire
c'est à dire la nécessité de démanteler
autant que faire se peut un certain
nombre de réseaux et
mais sont pas incompatibles avec mais
attention il faut un jour arrêter cet
état d'urgence
on va pas vivre en permanence je vous
état d'urgence et gvg vu même quelqu'un
dans mon propre parti proposé que l'état
d'urgence ne soit pas prolongée de trois
mois mais de six mois non non il faut
savoir sortir de l'état d'urgence
et oui et ça va être le plus difficile
puis s'arrête ici c'est la mène puisque
la menace est là et pour l'autre oui
sauf que il y a à revoir nos lois
effectivement il faut revoir les lois
qui permettent certain nombre de
perquisitions
il faut revoir un certain nombre de nos
lois il faut remettre réactualiser les
lois normales qui permettent à la police
la justice aux renseignements d'agir à
partir de ce moment là n'a plus besoin
d'état d'urgence
tout à l'heure vous avez dit quelque
chose sur l'état d'urgence on n'avait
pas tiré les conclusions de l'état
d'urgence après mais moins janvier après
les agents paris sg disent exactement
qu'on n'avait pas mis les têtes malagré
arbresle mois de janvier le mois de
janvier on a vu que nous étions attaqués
sur notre terrain il y avait donc
charlie hebdo hyper cacher on oublie
aussi tv une femme policier est
opérationnel l'état d'urgence est un
moment on savait qu'il y avait donc des
réseaux dans notre pays sur notre
terrain qui venait de belgique où elle
s'était trouvée bien sûr n'a dû le
mettre avant on a pu peut-être évité le
bataclan encore une fois je ne jette pas
la pierre à quiconque
on n'a pas voulu mettre l'état d'urgence
et on n'a pas pris de mesures
importantes après le mois de janvier
et ça c'est dramatique à radio globo
ouvrir un dossier qui est assez
encombrant pour le gouvernement c'est
celui de la construction de l'aéroport
de notre dame des landes a certainement
entendu parler
nous la vérité d'un référendum ou d'une
consultation qui ont été annoncées par
le président de la république mais
manuel valls et allez un petit peu plus
loin cette semaine car devant les
députés il annoncé que tous pour réparer
mais d'ici un mois
des explications de sophie nnomo
couturier l'ambiance est agitée dans
l'hémicycle le sujet qui fâche le
référendum local annoncée par françois
hollande sur le
aussi notre dame des landes c'est un
déni de démocratie
ce référendum est malvenue alors que les
urnes bien à plusieurs reprises et
encore dernièrement aux élections
régionales de portée des équipes
favorable à ce projet embarrassé sous le
regard de ségolène royal le premier
ministre défend l'idée de ce référendum
et met en avant une légitimité
supplémentaire avant d'esquisser un
semblant de calendrier en nous donnant
encore quelques semaines un mois au plus
avec la ministre de l'écologie les
consultations nécessaires ont lieu à la
fois sur la question qui sera posée sur
le périmètre de la consultation et sur
les modalités parce que personne qui
s'ignore ça a été rappelé depuis jeudi
dernier
toute une série de problématiques
juridiques des problèmes juridiques et
non des moindres il n'existerait aucun
cadre légal pour ce référendum local qui
relèvent de la compétence de l'état
l'exécutif espère pourtant que la
consultation pourra se dérouler avant
l'été questions constitutionnelles 2003
voilà et donc vous revenez sur ce
principe de modifier ce constitutionnel
on en sait un petit peu plus
visiblement ce sera une consultation
uniquement sur la loire atlantique
ça sent quand même l'improvisation est
allé c'est l'improvisation et c'est
illégal
en 2003 il a été décidé qu'on pouvait
faire des référendums locaux à la
condition que ce soit de la compétence
locale que notre dame notation mais
notre dame des landes et de la
compétence nationale
donc ils n'ont pas le droit et on a vu
le président du conseil régional et même
régional dire des on n'a pas le droit de
le faire constitutionnellement donc
c'est d'une improvisation absolue
pourquoi parceque ils ont racoler des
écologistes qui sont charmants demeurant
vincent jean vincent placé notre
sénateur barbara pompili madame coche
tout ça il fallait bien les attraper et
il fallait bien essayer de leur donner
un peu de miel et le miel c'était le
référendum et j'ai un de mes collègues
qui a dit à juste titre ça fait
plusieurs élections qui se sont passées
et qui ont quasiment validé le
référendum de notre dame des landes
on l'a validé à chaque élection les
candidats qui disait je suis pour ont
été élues et on attendant qu'est ce
qu'on fait ce qu'il faut évacuer par la
force des analystes qui restent sur
place
il faut un état de droit où ben oui faut
naîtra de droit la force mais bien
entendu on va pas la donne et que
sais-je à 15 degrés pour ben on attend
envoya plus d'état y a plus d'état que
vous voulez vous qu'on attende en attend
rien on va faire un référendum et après
une fois qu'on aura fait le référendum
si jamais il a lieu et que le référendum
dit oui qu'est ce qu'on fait avec les à
10 aujourd'hui vous savez maintenant
vous devez partir il faut dire non et
alors et l'état va vers quoi rien sur ce
dossier des tannes ferrari ont coûté
l'état j parce que ayrault et le député
de nantes qui est pour
c'est son bébé si l'on peut dire mais
ils ont pris d'un gouvernement d ceux
des écolos qui sont particulièrement
content on ne sait plus où on en est
voilà les écolos sont arrivés parce que
c'était le dernier tour de manège
gouvernementale
et s'il ne rentrait pas un manège cette
fois ci jamais une aura été ministre
pour eux c'était finalement l'objectif
principal c'est d'être menis monsieur le
ministre jean vincent placé
madame la ministre pompidou vous rendez
compte pour eux ça doit illuminer leur
vie était donc le dernier tour de manège
alors on va revenir à l'actualité
politique
avec une deuxième mise en examen pour
nicolas sarkozy il voit sarkozy mis en
examen pour le financement illégal de sa
campagne dans le cadre de l' enquête sur
les comptes de sa campagne
présidentielle explications germain en
trio avec au total un budget évalué à
plus de 50 millions d'euros soit plus de
deux fois le plafond légal autorisé la
mise en examen nicolas sarkozy cible le
financement illégal de la campagne
présidentielle de 2012 sur les chefs d'
usage de faux d'escroquerie et d'abus de
confiance
l'ancien président de la république
bénéficie du statut de témoin assisté
ces soutiens reste aujourd'hui confiant
sur l'issue judiciaire
moi je ne veux pas répondre à la place
de nicolas sarkozy ou à la place de
n'importe quel autre candidat ça dépend
pour quoi on est mis en examen mais
dépend de beaucoup de choses mais c'est
une
c'est quelque chose qui relève de la
conscience de chacun jeu sinon sinon si
on porte un jugement ça veut dire que
non n'est plus présumé innocent mais
présumé coupable
rien n'aura été épargné à nicolas
sarkozy jusqu'à ménages chaque fois
qu'il ya eu des accusations
rappelez-vous bettencourt rappelez vous
la faire de la prise en charge des
amendes par l'ump
chaque fois ça a débouché sur un
non-lieu autre réaction celle d'alain
juppé
son principal rival pour 2017 sur
twitter un premier message pour
respecter la présomption d'innocence
sans oublier ses amitiés à l'ancien
président dans ces moments difficiles
certains républicains vont plus loin et
souhaite déjà revoir la législation en
vigueur
je pense que c'est l'occasion pour le
prochain présent la république de
proposer au parlement une révision du
mode de financement des campagnes
électorales
en attendant thierry herzog l'avocat de
nicolas sarkozy reste formel cette
deuxième mise en examen
n'empêche pas pour le moment d'être
candidat à la présidentielle de 2017
alors pour vous faire réagir sur les
propos de 2-1 faisant rien n'empêchera
n'est pas sarkozy d'être candidat il a
aussi dit qu'il faut pas être jugé deux
fois oui ça c'est très très curieux j'ai
effectivement il ya toute une discussion
aujourd'hui le conseil constitutionnel
aju
j'ai les comptes de campagne un sincère
comme d'ailleurs la fait la commission
nationale des comptes de campagne et a
donné une amende
donc a condamné nicolas sarkozy non
seulement à rembourser les 11 millions
d'euros donné théoriquement par l'état
et puis il ya eu une amende de qu'après
traces empreintes milot et a donc
remboursé
il a donc été condamné et là c'est vrai
que et à un vrai point est-ce qu'on peut
être condamnée deux fois et jugé deux
fois mais en tous les cas il a déjà été
condamné
donc on ne dise pas qu'il est totalement
innocent il a été condamné par le
conseil constitutionnel a remboursé une
partie et a eu une amende
voilà est-ce qu'il peut se présenter de
moins en moins de moins en moins 3
qu'est ce qui pourrait l'empêcher a
coûté déjà il y avait une jurisprudence
qui disait que quand un ministre est mis
en examen quelle que soit la raison
quelles que soient les conséquences il
devait démissionner vous voyez un
président de la république ancien
président public se représenter contre
d'ailleurs le même candidat qui l'a
battue donc françois hollande se
représentait alors qu'il est mis en
examen deux ou trois fois
moi j'aimerais qu'on ait un peu plus de
politique que l'on dirais-je scène est
compréhensible dans ces conditions
bernard debré peut-il rester à la tête
des républicains
c'est la même chose vous demander son
départ mais je vous aimerai je demande
soit bien seul parce que beaucoup de
gens sont en train de cirer les
chaussures mais je suis très clair
nicolas sarkozy ne devrait pas se
présenter aux élections présidentielles
et qu'ils en tirent les conséquences
complète qu'il s'en aille des
républicains ou alors qu'ils nous disent
je ne suis pas candidat mais je vais les
organiser avec les uns et les autres
mais enfin qu'on arrête de nous imposer
des investitures nous imposer le
programme de nicolas sarkozy est
vigoureuse et qu'il ne soit pas candidat
à l'élection présidentielle est bien sûr
dans le contexte aujourd'hui de la
justice qui pèse et le compagnon de
celle au bal nous allons pas rejouer
2012 avec françois hollande nicolas
sarkozy
the béraud marine le pen et c'était on
va jouer on va être la risée du monde
entier
et puis on le voit actuellement alors on
ne veut pas évidemment une élection par
des sondages mais les français le
rejette et ça va pas améliorer sa
situation dont j'aimerais que ce soit
plus clair
vous avez parlé tout à l'heure on va
parler d'un autre sujet vous avez parlé
tout à l'heure de renseignement il ya un
rapport annuel qui a été remis par jean
pierre raffarin qui est le président de
la délégation pour le renseignement au
sénat
ce rapport met en évidence le manque en
tout cas de moyens pour le renseignement
français regardez jean pierre raffarin a
présenté ce matin à la délégation
parlementaire au renseignement
les principales conclusions de ce
rapport carences majeures pointé par la
commission l'absence d'un vrai système
public d'évaluation du renseignement
dans un entretien au figaro
il plaide ainsi pour la création d'un
corps d'inspection des services de
renseignement il faut qu'à tout moment
les pouvoirs publics soient en mesure
d'évaluer le travail des services de
renseignement comme sont évalués les
autres politiques publiques par des
inspections générales ou la cour des
comptes
une nécessité qui selon lui lui
permettrait de faire un retour
d'expérience complet dans un contexte de
menaces terroristes
un avis partagé par christian cambon qui
voit également un moyen d'empêcher des
dérives au sein des renseignements
nous nous donnons cette possibilité de
pouvoir intervenir si nous nous
apercevions que des usages de la loi
n'était pas conforme à l'esprit et à la
pratique il doit en être fait autre fait
notable soulevés par le rapport
l'importance du renseignement humain
souvent sous-estimée par rapport aux
moyens technologiques
un point qui a pu être discuté ce matin
en présence des patrons de la djs y ait
de la dgse alors sur ce manque en tout
cas de moyens pour le renseignement il
est assez illustré aussi par tout ce qui
arrive sur le monde entier il ya le
patron de la msa le renseignement
américain qui est grandes oreilles qui
coûte un petit peu tout le monde qu'il
dit qu' on n'a pas réussi à décrypter
nous fameux décryptage d'un parisien
décrypter ce qui s'était passé pour les
jihadistes pour les terroristes qui ont
frappé en france si on avait réussi à
décrypter on
peut-être réussi à éviter ce qui se
passait il ya un vrai problème
donc ils ont un temps d'avancé sur nous
non parce que google refuse qu on
décrypte parce que vous rappelle qui a
refusé heureux oui pourquoi
parce que pour casser le code de
cryptage de votre téléphone c'est
absolument impossible donc il faut
trouver un moyen pour passer à côté du
code de tous les téléphones dont ceux
des terrains et la balance et les clairs
est ce que on peut dire aujourd'hui
qu'on va maintenant avoir une vie
totalement transparente à la disposition
de la dgd g62 des américains qui vont
pouvoir écouter absolument tout et
décrypter tout ils peuvent déjà écouté
décrypter tout dernier c'est un vrai
problème bernard debré sur ce point
manuel valls a pris le mode hyper
terrorisme en disant que nous serons
encore frappé c'est presque une
certitude il en paye ce mot en allemagne
vous êtes d'accord avec lui c'est le
libertarisme mais je dis que nous sommes
dans un hyper terrorisme nous ne voulons
pas réagir par une vraie guerre nous
envoyons des bombes
on sait plus d'ailleurs qui envoient des
bombes sur qui les turcs envoient des
bombes sur les kurdes les kurdes sont en
train d'être aidés par le tan les russes
était absurde qu'est ce que c'est que
cette histoire on peut pas un jour se
mettre autour de la table pour dire nous
avons des terrorisme partout et soyons
ensemble qui est une coalition
alors on revient à l'assemblée nationale
avec une audition de laurent fabius dans
la commission des lois l'ex désormais
ex-ministre des affaires étrangères a
défendu son parcours et les pressenti
pour devenir le président du conseil
constitutionnel flora sauvage à 69 ans
laurent fabius a plaidé sa cause devant
les parlementaires
auditionné ce matin par la commission
des lois l'ex-ministre des affaires
étrangères a défendu son cv normalien
agrégé de lettres et énarque celui qui
fut en 1984 le plus jeune premier
ministre de france a mis en avant son
parcours professionnel
alors qu'il est pressenti pour devenir
le président du conseil constitutionnel
j'ai été élu député la première fois en
1978 j'ai exercé des fonctions locales
j'ai donc été conseiller municipal
adjoint au maire j'ai été conseiller
général au moment où ça s'appelait
encore comme ça j'ai été président de
région après l'énumération de ces
nombreuses fonctions laurent fabius a
tenté une opération de calinothérapie
auprès de sénateur pour la plupart
acquis à sa cause
il ya deux grandes catégories de députés
par rapport à la question du bicamérisme
ceux qui sont carrément contre et ceux
qui sont content mais ensuite qu'ils
vont devenir sénateur et moi je fais
partie de cette troisième catégorie gill
s'est passé et noah je ne crois pas
avoir pris position contre le sénat pour
une raison assez simple c'est que je
suis partisan de wickham éric au final
les questions qui fâchent sont restés
dans les tiroirs
les commissions des lois du sénat et de
l'assemblée nationale se sont prononcés
par 38 voix en faveur de la nomination
de laurent fabius parmi les membres du
conseil constitutionnel
il devrait donc succéder à jean-louis
debré début mars à une question est-ce
que c'est l'homme qu'il faut pour
succéder à votre frère jean louis debré
août et je pense que c'est le meilleur
des choix
c'est un homme qui a mûri en politique
qui ait eu des actions que j'ai combattu
bien entendu dans un certain nombre de
politiques pour vous de la part de
françois hollande est forcément je suis
apolitique jean-louis mon frère c'était
aussi un choix politique de chirac
mais c'est comme ça ils perdent leur
couleur politique une fois qu'ils sont
arrivés aux choristes bien entendu
pourquoi parce qu'ils ont un certain âge
et ça c'est important et qui n'ont plus
d'autre ambition c'est terminé une fois
qu'ils se sont plu président neuf ans
après ils ne vont pas se représenter
on va passer à la réforme du code du
travail en hausse un petit peu plus sur
le projet de loi qui sera annoncée le 9
mars par myriam el khomri la milice du
travail
il brise pour le moins quelques totem de
gauche on voit tous les détails avec
sophie normaux couturier
ils sont inscrits dans l'avant projet de
loi de réforme du travail
les trois fondamentaux le smic le cdi
les 35 heures maintenu aussi une
majoration minimum de 10% pour la
rémunération des heures supplémentaires
mais la durée maximale hebdomadaire
pourra être porté à 60 heures en cas de
circonstances exceptionnelles temps de
travail et salaires également modulable
pour une durée pouvant aller jusqu'à
cinq ans lorsqu'une entreprise souhaite
préserver l'emploi en cas de problèmes
économiques ou le développer pour
conquérir de nouveaux marchés
s'il n'est pas d'accord le salarié
pourra être licencié
les indemnités prud'homales en cas de
licenciement abusif seront plafonnées en
matière d'accords d'entreprise avec les
syndicats
les accords collectifs devront être
majoritaires et en cas de situation de
blocage des syndicats représentant au
moins 30 % des salariés pourront
demander la tenue d'un référendum à
venir sur ces questions dont 1,9 tonne
jean jaurès est avec nous notre
partenaire du scan katia sur la loi et
comment oui alors cette loi contient des
mesures comme qui vont assez loin et
s'est proposé par un gouvernement de
gauche qu'est ce que ça vous étonne ça
vous surprend ou au contraire vous en
féliciter écoutez je m'en félicite parce
que je ne voudrais pas qu'on dise et
d'une mesure de droite ou de gauche
c'est ce sont des mesures de bon sens
quand schoder je pense alors en
allemagne qui était à gauche fait arte 1
2 3 et à dire qu'il fait ces mêmes
mesures
il était à gauche il a sauvé l'allemagne
quand vous voyez cameron et ses
prédécesseurs ils ont fait ces mêmes
mesures
et ça a sauvé l'angleterre merci
françois hollande va coûter d'abord on
va voir si ça passe bah c'est pas
évident sauf que nombre d'entre eux
n'ont été forte vous n'êtes pas là les
attendait ce qui va se passer parce
qu'il ya la commission des lois il ya la
commission d'affaires reste en l'état
elle en effet il faut qu'on nous dise
oui moi je il ya des mesures qu'on va ce
que je vous disais le pire avec les
socialistes
je crains le pire pourquoi parce qu'ils
peuvent
affaire d amendement absurde et le
problème que l'on a c'est la loi c'est
tout ou rien où on va tous on est
content
alors qu'il ya certainement une grande
partie de mesures sur lesquelles nous
sommes pour nous voterons pour peut-être
vont-ils nous sortir du chapeau que les
allemands selon judas bon et vous pensez
qu'ils vont reculer mais évidemment
évidemment madame elle comme riz a déjà
dit qu'elle envisageait peut-être de
mettre l'article 49-3 puisque évidemment
françois hollande a dit le contraire
ce qu'ils m'ont tous une certaine
cohésion gouvernementale
mais ça on est habitués mais ça veut
dire que le principal obstacle
ce sont les socialistes les écolos
passer la majorité était alors est ce
que la majorité va accepter de se faire
tondre ou est ce que une le bon sens va
l'emporter bien sûr qu'il faut que le
bon sens l'emporté et l'autorité aussi
quand même c'est impliquant même de
l'autorité c'est à l'autorité je suis
pas sûr que le gouvernement sache ce que
c'est dans la parole repasser à la suite
la loupe du scan avec notre partenaire
s'est tout de suite
bonjour bernard debré bonjour on va
commencer cette séquence par deux images
la première c'est cette vitrine de
librairies qui a beaucoup circulé sur
twitter sur les réseaux sociaux
on y retrouve les livres de nicolas
sarkozy alain juppé france jean françois
copé et françois fillon
agrémenté vous savez de ses petits
commentaires facétieux parfois que
mettre les libraires dans les librairies
ces messages j'ai changé moi aussi moi
encore plus voilà qu'est ce que ça
qu'est ce que ça vous inspire cet
hommage humour l'humour français au bois
sablonneux je ne me gêne pas et c'est ça
veut dire que les politiques sont pris à
leur propre piège parce que je me
souviens de jean françois copé
le juge
jamais la langue de bois après il faut
essayer après il faisait bon voilà
qu'ils sont prêts leur propre c'est le
jeu le jeu la seconde séquence elle a
été tournée par les caméras du petit
journal de canal + ce week-end lors du
conseil national des républicains
elle met en scène brice hortefeux et
jean françois copé vous allez le voir
l'ambiance est assez glaciale regardez
jean françois copé est juste là chatel
et hortefeux approches vont ils saluent
écopé réponse
et
ambiance glaciale donc au vu de ces deux
documents est ce qu'il faut pas
s'inquiéter un peu de l'image que vous
renvoyez les républicains dans cette
période pré présidentielle rachida dati
elle dit quelque chose elle dit la
primaire ça rend le parti complètement
fou est ce que vous êtes d'accord
comme toujours elle a raison comme
churchill qui dit la république la
démocratie pardon c'est ce qui est pire
sauf carrez à d'autre mais ben oui la
primaire est indispensable mais c'est
sage ça rend un peu sur les candidats
envoient ou un vis-à-vis de votre parti
auprès des électeurs est ce que c'est
une bonne une bonne image non mais est
ce qu'on peut faire autre chose
n'oubliez pas simplement que ces
élections 2010 est peut-être très
particulière le deuxième tour va voir
s'affronter marine le pen contre soi la
droite soit la gauche ce n'est plus une
bataille droite gauche au deuxième tour
entre eux
le représentant du parti socialiste et
l'embarras entendez des menus party les
républicains c'est plus ça il faut
maintenant avoir un candidat dès le
premier tour qui rassemble qui rassemble
avec le centre la droite pour aller
combattre le front national au deuxième
tour
donc les primaires sont fondamentales
dispensable indispensable
le candidat dans ce dispositif que vous
soutenez ya pas inné c'est par un grand
secret ces il s'agit de françois fillon
oui j'ai pas un grand secret pourquoi
voulez-vous que j'ai un secret
c'est ce que la vérité il ya quelques
semaines vous disiez de lui vous êtes un
soutien un peu critique quand même biais
il faudrait qu'il soit un peu plus
kubina ce qui est un peu plus au combat
pour ce pour ce pour se démarquer
est ce que par exemple cette semaine il
aurait dû être plus offensif comme vous
l'avait été il ya quelques minutes après
la mise en examen de nicolas sarkozy par
exemple réclamé que nicolas sarkozy se
met en retrait de quelques pelles à moi
de le dire qu'à lui voilà donc on sait
que les candidats aux barrages sur ces
munitions la rondeur
il faut qu'il garde cette rondeur et
vous a besoin de la voir comment
expliquez vous que ça fonctionne aux
côtés des chefs d'entreprise par exemple
que son programme
visiblement un prime de ce côté là mais
que dans les sondages c'est radio g
robin wood et il est pas encore le
premier sondage tant s'en faut mais moi
je suis derrière lui parce que il est
honnête il est un bon programme et j'ai
ce qu'on appelle une certaine fidélité
c'est rare en politique et donc je garde
cette fidélité
je vais faire tout ce que je peux pour
l'aider avec d'autres il a beaucoup de
députés et sénateurs
je peins à l'opinion ça ne fonctionne
pas comme ça on verra en année on a
quelques mois vous pensez qu'il peut
gagner
je l'espère je vais vous dire oui il a
gagné va gagner mais vraiment je veux
dire je l'espère on va tout faire pour
ça c'est à dire que je vais aller avec
d'autres dans les villes de france je
vais en gironde je vais défendre
l'armure par exemple il faudrait qu'ils
font là j'avais le problème on l'a dit
souvent les politiques font un peu de
théâtre fait on quand on sort d'ici
quand on aura vu l'émission durera vous
avez été formidables
alors alors ça vous a plu ce que j'ai
dit ah je n'ai pas retenu mais votre
cravate était très très bien donc c'est
ça qui manque ce qu il faut
la faconde les gestes il faut qu'on
sente qu'il aime les électeurs mais des
comme ça françois fillon puisque nous y
sommes samedi midi les ting lindsey
wright dans la vie publique des timides
en force qui force un peu ce match il y
en a un autre comme
qui ne porte pas vraiment nicolas
sarkozy dans son coeur c'est votre frère
jean louis debré il est libéré dans
quelques jours de ses fonctions lundi de
président du conseil constitutionnel il
prépa apparemment un livre qui devrait
sortir au mois d'avril dans lequel il
reviendra sur son expérience et
notamment peut-être sur les pressions
qu'il a subies du en provenance du camp
de sarkozy notamment au moment de la
validation vous en parlais tout à
l'heure des comptes de campagne de
nicolas sarkozy
ça peut être une bombe pour pour pour
nick et de chasse et il faudra lui
demander quand j'étais avec le jeu
maintenant on va écouter il ya la
nécessité d'abord de ne rien dire tant
qu on est évidemment à ferrer ont libéré
peut-être pas non plus tout dire
pourquoi là parce que quand même quand
on est
à sa place des choses qui ne doivent pas
être dit il en oublie données il est
dans un état d'esprit joli dos mais j'en
sais rien demandé lui c'est un petit
conseil que vous donnez ne dit pas tout
mais dit il faut pas non plus se venger
d'accord pas de vendetta gym il reste
six minutes d'interview et votre frère
vous êtes aussi très proche de jacques
chirac est ce que vous l'avez vu
récemment est-ce que vous avez des
nouvelles à nous donner
non on est jugé d'abord pour deux
raisons d'abord parce que je les ai pas
vus récemment deuxièmement qu'il ya le
secret médical donc je ne dirai rien sur
jackie chan
on sait tous qu'il va pas bien placé
beaucoup merci mais on se retrouve la
semaine prochaine katia merci beaucoup
je vous remercie d'avoir accepté nos
terres mais devant lui c'est votre frère
on en parlait récemment jumeaux frère
jumeau merci bernard debré on se
retrouve très bientôt
très beau si le programme sur la chaîne
lcp et public sénat
qui